[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
Після училища потрапив до Криму.
В Криму пробув 5 років.
І потім цей начальник пішов на пенсію,
[Приазов'я, Бердянськ
Нижній Бердянський маяк]
і я замість нього прийшов,
додому повернувся.
З 1971 року нікуди не виїжджаю.
[Яків Федірко
Доглядач маяка]
На маяку тут, по сьогодні управляю ним.
В 1945 році ми приїхали, батька перевели сюди працювати з Маріуполя, відразу після війни.
В 1962 році почав працювати на маяку,
і загалом працюю досі.
В мене брат працював тут, дочка працює, дружина працювала.
Династія.
А побудували тому, що кораблі сідали,
тут же мілко, якщо косу обходити - мілина.
І кораблі сідали на мілину.
І тоді Воронцов прийняв рішення,
щоб на краю коси поставити маяк.
Світловий маяк працює вночі,
коли заходить сонце — вмикається,
коли сходить — вимикається.
Тепер все автоматично.
Раніше дивились, слідкували,
коли сонце заходить.
Таблиці були.
А тепер все автоматично.
Вікна ми протираємо, а штори вже не опускаємо,
тому що сучасна оптика стоїть.
Наш пункт забезпечує безпечний прохід кораблів Маріуполь-Бердянськ, Бердянськ-Керч.
Кораблів багато зараз.
Тут в нас зараз три, чотири або
навіть п'ять суден стоїть в черзі в порт.
Зараз же відвантаження зерна іде.
До наших обов'язків тут все входить:
прибирання, фарбування, обслуговування техніки.
Підіймаємося [нагору].
Черговий піднімається нагору.
Підніматись...
Зараз я... [важко дихає]
Тепер мені тут хлопчина молодий допомагає,
донька піднімається.
Бачив, це вже стоїть оптика.
Тут дублер у разі поломки, якби щось трапилось,
то все запускається автоматично.
Це наш маячок.
А це маяк до....
В 1957 році відбудували його.
Він же був зруйнований.
Коли німці відходили, вони його зірвали.
Був купол вежі, в 1957 році відновили
ліхтарну систему і технічне приміщення.
Це я.
Це з Одеси кореспонденти знімають, в той час ще.
Ну що, все.
Пішли донизу.
[Оператор
Дмитро Охріменко]
[Монтаж
Микола Носок]
[Музика
Endless Melancholy]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]